This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the summer of 2002, Tatiana Kim took her first trip abroad. She was going to Anson, South Korea, which is a city that's about a half an hour drive outside of Seoul. I was visiting Anson to spend the summer break with my grandparents. They had recently moved into a very special apartment complex. That's Tatiana, by the way. Even though on the surface it seemed like any other building, there were these little details that stuck out to me.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2002年夏天，塔蒂亚娜·金进行了她的第一次出国旅行。她要去韩国的安山，那是一座距离首尔车程大约半小时的城市。我当时去安山是为了和祖父母一起度过暑假。他们最近搬进了一个非常特殊的公寓大楼。顺便说一句，那就是塔蒂亚娜。尽管表面上它看起来像任何其他建筑，但有一些小细节引起了我的注意。
The holes and elevators were a little wider and had handrails all the way across for people to hold onto. And for some reason, there was also a red cross office right on the premises. But the most distinctive feature about this complex was the people who lived there. There were about a thousand residents who were all elderly, and even though everybody was of Korean descent, they all spoke Russian. Sometimes, I'd meet other teenagers who were visiting their grandparents, but just like me, none of them spoke any Korean on the Russian. In the kitchens, our grandmothers would cook us both,
这些大厅和电梯稍微宽了一点，全长都装有扶手供人们抓握。而且不知为何，大楼里还设有一个红十字会办公室。但这个综合大区最独特的特征是住在那里的人。大约有一千名居民，他们全都是老年人，尽管每个人都有朝鲜族血统，但他们都说俄语。有时，我会遇到其他来探望祖父母的青少年，但就像我一样，他们除了俄语之外都不会说任何朝语。在厨房里，我们的祖母会为我们两个做，
panchang and borsh. And that's because every person in this complex came here from the same place, an island off the coast of Russia called Sakelin. In Russian, the complex is called Sakhlin Village. But in Korean, this settlement has a different name, Gohang Maid, meaning hometown village. Gohang Maid was constructed specifically as a settlement for people like my grandparents. ethnic Koreans who had returned to the country after being trapped for decades on Saeho-lin. Separated from their homeland and abandoned in the midst of huge geopolitical events, tens
拌饭和罗宋汤。这是因为这个综合大区里的每个人都是从同一个地方来到这里的，那是俄罗斯海岸外的一个岛屿，叫做萨哈林岛。在俄语中，这个大区被称为萨哈林村。但在朝语中，这个定居点有一个不同的名字，即“故乡村”，意思是家乡的村庄。故乡村是专门为像我祖父母这样的人建造的定居点。在被困在萨哈林岛数十年后，朝鲜族人回到了这个国家。在巨大的地缘政治事件中与祖国分离并被抛弃，数十
of thousands of Koreans spent nearly 50 years stranded behind the iron curtain, waiting for a chance to return home. I grew up on Sauceline. It's a long skinny island of the Russian coast just north of Japan. In fact, it's so close to Japan that when you stand on the southern tip of the island, you can actually pick up a Japanese cell signal. Winters can get very cold and snowy there. Even in the summer months, the average temperature doesn't usually
万朝鲜人在铁幕后面度过了近50年的困境，等待着回家的机会。我在萨哈林岛长大。那是俄罗斯海岸边、日本正北方一个又长又瘦的岛屿。事实上，它离日本如此之近，以至于当你站在岛的最南端时，你实际上可以收到日本的手机信号。那里的冬天会非常寒冷和多雪。即使在夏季，平均温度通常也不会
get above 70 degrees Fahrenheit. Apparently, Socklin used to be the home of Azaris penal colony and Anton Chekhov once described it as hell. I swear, he was wrong though. It's a beautiful place to live. I'll take your word over Chekhov's. When I started traveling to other countries, the first question people usually ask is where you from. When I answer from Russia, I get puzzled looks. You don't look Russian, they usually say, but there are a lot of Koreans in Saoho-Lin, and we've been there for a long time. Throughout its history, control of Saoho Sucland has passed back and forth between
超过华氏70度。显然，萨哈林岛过去是沙皇流放地所在地，安东·契诃夫曾将它描述为人间地狱。我发誓，不过他错了。这是一个居住的好地方。我宁愿相信你的话，也不愿相信契诃夫的话。当我开始去其他国家旅行时，人们通常问的第一个问题是你来自哪里。当我回答来自俄罗斯时，我得到了困惑的表情。他们通常会说，你看起来不像俄罗斯人，但萨哈林岛有很多朝鲜人，而且我们在那里已经很久了。在其历史中，对萨哈林的控制权在
two powerful empires, Russia and Japan. Around the turn of the 20th century, Russian Japan was fighting a war of a territory in East Asia, and by 1905 Russia had lost. So not only lost, but completely decimated. This is J. Hyeong Park, assistant professor at the Education University of Hong Kong. He says that under the terms of Russia's laws, Korea came under Japanese control. And Russia was forced to give up some of its territory, which included the southern half of Sao Han-lin. After the war, Sao Han-lin was split at the 50th parallel, and given to Japan. At a time, people used to cook a country by parallel, like a cake.
两个强大的帝国俄罗斯和日本之间反复易手。20世纪之交，俄国和日本正在为东亚的一片领土打仗，到1905年俄国战败了。所以不仅战败，而且被彻底击溃。这是香港教育大学助理教授朴智衡（音）。他说，根据俄国法律的条款，朝鲜置于日本的控制之下。而俄罗斯被迫放弃了部分领土，其中包括萨哈林岛的南部。战后，萨哈林岛在北纬50度处被分割，并交给了日本。当时，人们习惯按纬度像切蛋糕一样分割一个国家。
Although the environment was fridged, Soklin was valuable, because it was rich with natural resources like coal, timber, and fish. But Japan needed to bring in cheap labor to extract those resources. Which is how Koreans ended up on Saan-Hlan. At this point, the economy of Korea was severely weakened, and there were hardly any jobs left in the country. There was, however, plenty of work for those who were willing to travel north
尽管环境严寒，但萨哈林很有价值，因为它富含煤炭、木材和鱼类等自然资源。但日本需要引进廉价劳动力来开采这些资源。这就是朝鲜人最终来到萨哈林岛的原因。此时，朝鲜的经济严重衰弱，国内几乎没有剩余的工作岗位。然而，对于那些愿意向北旅行
to the Japanese controlled half of Saan-Hlan and brave the harsh conditions of the island. When Japan entered World War II, the government needed their own materials to fuel their military. And with Japanese men drafted into combat, more and more Koreans were forced to work in the timber yards and coal mines on the island as conscripted workers. 그가 모집자들이 마이거였어요. 이는 제 마이그란 마이터의 마이터가 born even seen as real people. So even if they died, they wouldn't be properly buried. She's saying this was the place as where workers were sent to, and a lot of people died.
到日本控制的萨哈林半岛并勇敢面对岛上严酷环境的人来说，有很多工作。当日本加入第二次世界大战时，政府需要他们自己的材料来为其军队提供燃料。随着日本男子被征召入伍，越来越多的朝鲜人被迫作为被征召的劳工在岛上的木材厂和煤矿工作。他招募的人是麦格雷（音）。这就是我的麦格雷的麦格雷的麦格雷甚至不被当成真正的人看。所以即使他们死了，他们也不会被妥善安葬。她说这是一个把工人送去的地方，很多人都死了。
So Korean migrants ended up on a remote island working in harsh conditions on behalf of the Japanese Empire. That is, until August 15, 1945. It was a huge occasion marked all over the world. And in Korea, the end of the Second World War was celebrated as Liberation Day. The movement went 35 years of Japanese colonial rule, finally came to an end. 23 million Koreans achieved the freedom from Japanese oppression against which they had never ceased to fight. Towards the end of the war, Soviet forces invaded the southern half of Soklin, and as part of the Japanese surrender, the entire island became the territory of the USSR.
因此，朝鲜移民最终来到一个偏远的岛屿上，代表日本帝国在恶劣的条件下工作。直到1945年8月15日。这是一个在全世界都被铭记的重大时刻。在朝鲜，第二次世界大战的结束被庆祝为光复节。历经35年日本殖民统治的运动终于迎来了终点。2300万朝鲜人从日本的压迫中赢得了自由，他们从未停止过与这种压迫的斗争。在战争快结束时，苏联军队入侵了萨哈林岛南部，作为日本投降的一部分，整个岛屿成为了苏联的领土。
This meant that all the Japanese and Korean people who were living there needed to return to their home countries because they were now on foreign soil. In Soklin alone, there were 400,000 Japanese citizens who needed to be repatriated. And because many currents were brought to Soklin by the Japanese government, they expected to return with them, many waited at the port alongside the Japanese nationals as the boards began arriving in Soklin to take people home. And then Japanese were taken to Japan, but not Koreans. This is Chang-Ju's song, Senior Lecturer in Korean and Asian Studies at the University of
这意味着所有居住在那里的日本和朝鲜人由于现在身处外国土地，都需要返回他们的祖国。仅在萨哈林，就有40万日本公民需要被遣返。由于许多朝鲜人是被日本政府带到萨哈林的，他们期望与他们一起回去，许多人随着船只开始抵达萨哈林接人们回家，在日本国民旁边在港口等待。然后日本人被带去了日本，但朝鲜人没有。这是奥克兰大学韩国和亚洲研究高级讲师张柱成（音）。
Auckland. He says that Koreans on Saan-Holun were left behind. That's because when Japan surrendered, it was forced to give up many of its colonies, including Korea. Legally, until then, Koreans were Japanese citizens, because Korea was a direct part of a Japanese empire. This complicated the status of Koreans on the island, because they weren't Japanese citizens anymore. But they also didn't have a functional Korean government yet
他说萨哈林的朝鲜人被留在了后面。那是因为当日本投降时，它被迫放弃了许多殖民地，包括朝鲜。从法律上讲，在此之前，朝鲜人是日本公民，因为朝鲜是日本帝国直接的一部分。这使岛上朝鲜人的地位变得复杂，因为他们不再是日本公民了。但他们当时也还没有一个运转正常的朝鲜政府
to help them get back home. So an estimated 23,500 Koreans were trapped on Sao Han and had no way of returning. So all these Koreans, no one claimed and no one paid attention, they were all desperate. South Korea was closely affiliated with the capitalist US, while the North stayed aligned with the communist Soviet Union. The USSR actually did allow for the repatriation of Sakhling Koreans, but only to their ally nation, North Korea. And there was one enormous problem with that. These conscript workers were mostly from southern province, Busan and Jol-ah province, so they are being repatriated to the North- the North Korea, which is not their home land actually. And the truth is, the Soviet Union had no reason to help
来帮助他们回家。因此，估计有23500名朝鲜人被困在萨哈林，没有办法回去。所以所有这些朝鲜人，没有人认领，也没有人关注，他们都绝望了。韩国与资本主义美国紧密结盟，而北方则保持与共产主义苏联结盟。苏联确实允许遣返萨哈林朝鲜人，但只能遣返到他们的盟友国家朝鲜。这其中有一个巨大的问题。这些被征召的劳工大多来自南部省份釜山和全罗道，所以他们被遣返到北方——朝鲜，这实际上并不是他们的家乡。事实是，苏联没有理由帮助
Sahel and Koreans return to their home country. With hundreds of thousands of Japanese workers now gone, the USSR was reliant on Korean labor to continue developing the island. Soviet Union always need people to develop, to maintain certain level of your production of foods, fishery, and mining, a building railway and so on. Someone had to be there to work in the mines, cut the timber and fish for food. Why allow Koreans to live when they were a valuable workforce? The first generation of Koreans on Soklin had a difficult time adjusting to life
萨哈林朝鲜人返回他们的祖国。随着数十万日本工人现已离开，苏联依靠朝鲜劳动力继续开发该岛。苏联总是需要人来开发，来维持一定水平的食品、渔业和采矿生产，建造铁路等等。必须有人留在那里在矿井工作、砍伐木材和捕捞食物。当朝鲜人是宝贵的劳动力时，为什么要让他们离开？第一代萨哈林朝鲜人在苏联统治下
under the USSR. They didn't speak the Russian language and many had never even seen Westerners before. A new reality under the Soviet Union was absolutely foreign to them. What made things harder was that most people had come to the island as temporary workers. So parents, siblings, and sometimes spouses and children will have to in Korea. This is my grandmother again. She's saying that my grandfather was one of those people who had to live everything behind when he came to Saagalan.
适应生活有一段艰难的时期。他们不会说俄语，许多人甚至以前从未见过西方人。苏联统治下的新现实对他们来说完全是陌生的。让事情变得更艰难的是，大多数人来岛上时都是临时工人。因此，父母、兄弟姐妹，有时还有配偶和孩子都留在朝鲜。这是我的祖母。她说我的祖父是那些来到萨哈林时不得不抛弃一切的人之一。
She says my grandfather didn't want to go to Saagalan, but he was conscripted to work for a couple of years. He had left behind a sweetheart who was waiting for him back in Korea. But by the time they were ended, there was no way to return home. They lost all the hope and they were in despair because they suddenly realized they cannot go home. They lost any motivation to work. They said we drank and we sang. They can not go home. They lost any motivation to work. They said we drank, and we sang.
她说我祖父不想去萨哈林，但他被征召去工作几年。他在朝鲜留下了等待他归来的恋人。但当一切结束时，已经没有办法回家了。他们失去了所有的希望，陷入了绝望，因为他们突然意识到自己无法回家了。他们失去了任何工作的动力。他们说我们喝酒，我们唱歌。他们无法回家。他们失去了一切工作的动力。他们说我们喝酒，我们唱歌。
And the songs they were singing, and that, you know, I want to go my homeland and that kind of, you know, they were really desperate for a while. This song, Come Back to Busan Port, was really popular among Saehlin Koreans. It's about missing loved ones who have been separated from Korea. By the 1950s, it was clear that this problem of repatriation was not going to be solved anytime soon.
他们唱的歌，你知道的，我想回我的祖国之类的，你知道的，他们有一段时间真的很绝望。这首歌《回到釜山港》在萨哈林朝鲜人中非常受欢迎。它讲述的是思念与朝鲜分离的亲人。到了20世纪50年代，很明显，这个遣返问题在短期内是无法解决的。
The Korean War and the Cold War both made it impossible to negotiate a diplomatic return. The South Korean government was busy rebuilding its country, and the Soviet government needed the labor. So, the USSR started allowing Soklin Koreans to apply for Soviet citizenship. But many people outright refused. In their eyes, citizenship meant commitment to the Soviet Union. This is Yuletzin, senior researcher of the Sakhalin Regional Museum, speaking to me in Russian.
朝鲜战争和冷战都使得通过外交途径谈判回归成为不可能。韩国政府正忙于重建国家，而苏联政府需要劳动力。因此，苏联开始允许萨哈林朝鲜人申请苏联国籍。但许多人断然拒绝。在他们眼里，国籍意味着对苏联的效忠。这是萨哈林地区博物馆高级研究员尤利娅·季娜（音），用俄语对我说。
She says that in the eyes of these Koreans adopting Soviet citizenship meant that you were given up on the dream of one day returning home. Well, the question is, for my family, it means because my mother, my uncle, is also a Sahel in Korean. And she says, to this day, your mother and aunt are not Russian citizens. They don't have a passport, just a resident's permit for stateless citizens. This created a lot of challenges for people. Every time they wanted to leave their town for any reason, they had to ask permission
她说，在这些朝鲜人眼里，取得苏联国籍意味着你放弃了一天重返家园的梦想。嗯，问题是，对我的家庭来说，这意味着因为我的母亲、我的叔叔也是萨哈林朝鲜人。她说，直到今天，你的母亲和阿姨都不是俄罗斯公民。她们没有护照，只有无国籍公民的居留许可证。这给人们带来了很多挑战。每当他们想出于任何原因离开城镇时，他们都必须向当地警察局请求
from the local police station. Things like visiting family or going to funeral in a different part of Saqlun were more difficult. Udsa says that stateless citizens had problems everywhere that others don't have. The reality of the situation was that returning home was impossible. The Soviet Union was not going to allow them to leave, and Korea and Japan were not coming to rescue them. So if politics could not change, Sakhling Koreans would have to. They needed to adapt if they wanted to build a better future for themselves and for the next generation.
批准。诸如探亲或去萨哈林不同地区参加葬礼之类的事情变得更加困难。乌德萨（音）说，无国籍公民在其他地方没有的问题，他们在到处都有。现实情况是，回家是不可能的。苏联不会允许他们离开，而韩国和日本也不会来拯救他们。因此，如果政治无法改变，萨哈林朝鲜人就必须改变。如果他们想为自己和下一代创造一个更好的未来，他们就需要适应。
They learned Russian and send their children to Soviet schools. Koreans integrated more, and in the process Korean culture on Sahel and started becoming its own unique identity. You can tell that Sahel and Korean culture, even first generation culture by then, it was a mixture of Korean culture, Japanese culture, and Russian culture layer in their language life, in their food. You can even see this blending of culture in the way my grandmother communicates. She's saying that when she speaks, sometimes Japanese comes out, sometimes Russian or Korean.
他们学习俄语，把孩子送进苏联学校。朝鲜人更加融入当地，在这个过程中，萨哈林上的朝鲜文化开始形成其自己独特的身份。你可以看出萨哈林朝鲜文化，甚至是那时的第一代文化，它是朝鲜文化、日本文化和俄罗斯文化的混合体，在他们的语言生活、他们的食物中层层叠加。你甚至可以在我祖母交流的方式中看到这种文化的融合。她说，当她说话时，有时会冒出日语，有时是俄语或朝语。
Growing up, I saw this hybrid culture all around me. For the new year's celebration, we would make Russian dumplings with kimchi mixed in it. And every year when we honored our ancestors who passed away, our sobering would have incense and a bottle of Russian vodka on it. As far back as I can remember, being ethnically Korean in Russia was something to be proud of. Since the end of World War II, there was essentially no communication between the USSR and South Korea. There were no phone calls and no mail service between separated family members,
在成长过程中，我周围到处都能看到这种混合文化。为了庆祝新年，我们会做掺有泡菜的俄罗斯饺子。每年我们纪念去世的祖先时，我们的桌上都会供奉着熏香和一瓶俄罗斯伏特加。在我记事起，在俄罗斯拥有朝鲜族血统是一件值得骄傲的事情。自二战结束以来，苏联和韩国之间基本上没有沟通。分离的亲人之间没有电话，也没有邮件服务，
so many people weren't sure if their loved ones were even still alive. Most people behind the Iron Curtain could only rely on their memories of the poor and rural country they had left behind, and many even believed that South Koreans were worse off than in the North. Which was actually true for a little while, but from the 1960s onward, the South Korean government became rapidly recovering from the devastation of war. By the 1980s, South Korea was flourishing, and one event in particular gave Sakhling Koreans a glimpse of just how far their country had come. 1998년에 서울을 88 soul Olympic games, everyone watched. And that was a time when Korean diaspora,
所以许多人甚至不确定他们心爱的人是否还活着。铁幕后面的大多数人只能依靠他们对离开的那个贫穷乡村国家的记忆，许多人甚至认为韩国的情况比朝鲜还要糟。这在一段时间内确实是真的，但从20世纪60年代开始，韩国政府从战争的满目疮痍中迅速恢复过来。到了20世纪80年代，韩国正在蓬勃发展，其中有一个事件让萨哈林朝鲜人得以一窥他们的国家已经取得了多大的进步。1988年的首尔奥运会，每个人都观看了。那是朝鲜 diaspora，
in Soviet Union, they felt it's extremely proud. So all the Koreans, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, all, This is my dad. He was 32 years old at the time and was watching the soul Olympics with his family. He says that everyone in Savelin watched. The house was full of elderly Koreans sitting in front of the television. He says that everyone kept talking about how developed Korea had become and how much progress it made. During the competitions, the older people were acting like kids again, cheering like children. Seen South Korea as a developed nation and watching Soviet and Korean athletes competing The world was changing, new political ties were forming, and technology was evolving. All of these things led to a line of communication finally opening up between Sul and Koreans and their home country, which happened for the first time in the year 1990, surprisingly, on national public television. This is from a KBS live broadcast called Reunions of Separated Families for Sao Ha-Hul in Koreans.
在苏联，他们感到极其自豪。所以所有的朝鲜人，所有的……这是我爸爸。他当时32岁，正和家人一起观看首尔奥运会。他说萨哈林的所有人都看了。屋里挤满了坐在电视机前老年朝鲜人。他说每个人都在谈论韩国变得多么发达，取得了多大的进步。在比赛期间，老年人又像小孩子一样行事，像小孩子一样欢呼。看到韩国作为一个发达国家，看着苏联和朝鲜运动员同场竞技。世界在改变，新的政治纽带在形成，科技在演变。所有这些事情最终促成了萨哈林朝鲜人与他们的祖国之间开启沟通热线，这在1990年首次发生，令人惊讶的是，在国家公共电视台。这是来自KBS的名为《为萨哈林朝鲜人重聚离散家庭》的直播节目。
The goal of the special was to reunite Korean families who had been torn apart by war and geopolitical drama. South Korea and the Soviet Union arranged a video conference call where separated families were finally able to speak again over video link. In many cases, people were learning that their relatives were still alive on national television. In this clip, a Sakhling Korean man is seeing his mother for the first time in 45 years. He keeps saying mom, mom while she cries uncontrollably. Он все это говорит, что мама, мама, когда она угрозала, и контроллась. Вот кто сидел, не было на душах, все плаканы, все.
这个特别节目的目标是让因战争和地缘政治戏剧而骨肉分离的朝鲜家庭团聚。韩国和苏联安排了一次视频会议通话，离散家庭终于可以通过视频连线再次交谈。在许多情况下，人们是在国家电视台上得知他们的亲戚仍然活着。在这个片段中，一名萨哈林朝鲜人男子45年来第一次见到他的母亲。他一直在叫妈妈，妈妈，而她则无法控制地哭了。他一直在说，妈妈，妈妈，当她受到威胁时，控制不住了。当时坐在那里的人，没有谁不落泪的，所有人都在哭，所有人都……
Здесь мой дед, и, again, он сказал, что никто не был в дефон. Все было в дефон. Большинство, кто по телемисту участвовал, она большинство все знала. His mother, my Babushka, was there watching too. She knew many of the people who participated in this broadcast. She would cry and she would say, I know her. And then she would tell him what their names were and what she remembered about them. When the Soviet Union collapsed in 1991,
这里是我的爷爷，再说一次，他说没有人无动于衷。所有人都在动容。大多数在电视上参与的人，绝大多数都知道。他的母亲，我的巴布什卡（奶奶），当时也在看。她认识很多参与这次广播的人。她会哭，她会说，我认识她。然后她会告诉他他们的名字是什么，以及她对他们的记忆。当苏联在1991年解体时，
Koreans on Soklin finally had an opening to return home, some went immediately. Returns mostly took place through visiting programs assisted by humanitarian organizations or by religious groups. But Yulidin from the Soklin Regional Museum says that the early years of return were incredibly rocky. She says it was a nightmare. People who really wanted to leave mostly had to either use their own money
萨哈林岛上的朝鲜人终于有了回家的机会，有些人立即动身了。回归主要通过人道主义组织或宗教团体协助的探访项目进行。但来自萨哈林地区博物馆的尤利娅·季娜说，回归的头几年异常艰难。她说那是一场噩梦。真正想要离开的人大多只能要么动用自己的钱，
or rely on relatives in South Korea. There was no governmental support to help people resettle at that time. They were people who wanted to leave Saham just for the sake of living. For them returning to Korea was the end goal. Many older Saham Koreans had been waiting for so long to repatriate that they were willing to move back at any cost. Some sold everything they had. Others left their spouses if they refused to go with them.
要么依靠在韩国的亲戚。当时没有任何政府支持来帮助人们重新安置。他们是仅仅为了活下去而想要离开萨哈林的人。对他们来说，回到韩国是最终的目标。许多年长的萨哈林朝鲜人等待遣返的时间太长了，以至于他们不惜一切代价也愿意搬回去。有些人卖掉了他们拥有的一切。其他人如果配偶拒绝跟他们一起走，就抛弃了配偶。
For many who returned in those early years, it was not the reunion they dreamed of for five decades. South Korea had changed completely, and now they were strangers in a new country, which should have felt familiar was foreign to them. Yule says that because many of the people repatriating were older, their relatives had already died, and at this late stage of life, it was difficult to start over again.
对于许多在那些早年回归的人来说，这不是他们梦想了五十年的团聚。韩国已经彻底改变了，现在他们在一个新的国家里成了陌生人，这个本该让他们感到熟悉的地方对他们来说却是陌生的。尤利娅说，由于许多被遣返的人年纪较大，他们的亲戚已经去世了，而在人生的这个晚期阶段，重新开始是很困难的。
It was just an irrational desire to return. At the beginning, homeland is a nice place, but later on, homeland can become a real... Regardless of the difficulties, the goal of successful repatriation never went away. Throughout the 1990s, the new Russian government was much more open to letting people leave the country. The Korean and Japanese governments also started to acknowledge the existence of Soklin Koreans and wanted to do something to correct past injustices. In order to make a man's foe's part in using forced labor, the government of Japan earmarked 3.2 billion yen to pay for the transit, housing, and financial assistance of Sakhling Koreans.
这只是一种不理智的回归渴望。起初，故乡是个好地方，但后来，故乡可能会变成一个真正的……无论有什么困难，成功遣返的目标从未消失。整个20世纪90年代，新的俄罗斯政府对允许人们离开国家要开放得多。韩国和日本政府也开始承认萨哈林朝鲜人的存在，并希望做点什么来纠正过去的不公正。为了弥补在强迫劳动中扮演的角色，日本政府拨出32亿日元来支付萨哈林朝鲜人的交通、住房和财政援助。
The South Korean government provided land to build housing on. It was a joint venture between Russia, Japan, and then Korean government work together. It's an incredible diplomatic achievement. I understand for Russia, Japan, and Korea, because these three countries that they cannot talk each other, they have so many past issues, they agreed to do this and then they came through. So it's a big achievement. This international cooperation allowed people from Soklin
韩国政府提供了用于建设住房的土地。这是俄罗斯、日本和韩国政府共同合作的一个合资项目。这是一个不可思议的外交成就。我理解对于俄罗斯、日本和韩国来说，因为这三个国家无法相互交谈，他们有太多的历史遗留问题，他们同意这样做并且做到了。所以这是一个巨大的成就。这种国际合作让萨哈林的人们
to move to a number of housing complexes and nursing homes across South Korea. And in the year 2000, a formal repatriation program was established. The first and only settlement constructed specifically for Soklin Koreans was built in South Korea. It was Kerhang-M Il, a hometown village. The very same community that I visited my grandparents at, in An Sun.
得以搬进韩国各地的多个住宅小区和疗养院。在2000年，一个正式的遣返项目建立起来了。第一个也是唯一一个专门为萨哈林朝鲜人建造的定居点在韩国建成。这就是“故乡村”，一个家乡的村庄。也就是我拜访我祖父母的那个社区，在安山。
This complex was meant to address the problems associated with repatriation. Residents didn't just get free housing, but a support system to navigate a new country. More than a thousand elderly Sakhlin Koreans received a small apartment, along with a modest pension since most of the residents had retired or couldn't work. There was good healthcare available and friendly stuff. They also had access to the Korean and Japanese Red Cross on-site, who helped residents get anything they might need for their new homes.
这个综合大区旨在解决与遣返相关的问题。居民不仅得到了免费住房，还得到了适应新国家的支柱系统。一千多名老年萨哈林朝鲜人获得了一套小公寓，以及一份适度的养老金，因为大多数居民已经退休或无法工作。那里有良好的医疗保健和友好的员工。他们还可以使用现场的韩国和日本红十字会，红十字会帮助居民获得他们新家可能需要的任何东西。
Today, the community comprises eight different apartment buildings and houses more than 700 people. There's a lounge for plain Ma-jong and Lotto, which is like the Russian version of Bingo, and a room for plain table tennis. There's even a local choir and a karaoke room, all just for former Soklin Koreans. Residents have basically everything they would ever need without having to leave this small, Russian-Korean community. My grandma says that Kohangmael is quite livable and she took a liking to it.
今天，该社区由八栋不同的公寓楼组成，居住着700多人。这里有一个供人打麻将和玩乐透（类似于俄版宾果游戏）的休息室，还有一个打乒乓球的房间。甚至还有一个当地的合唱团和一个卡拉OK房，全部专为前萨哈林朝鲜人服务。居民们基本上拥有他们所需要的一切，而无需离开这个小小的俄罗斯-朝鲜社区。我奶奶说故乡村相当宜居，她挺喜欢这里的。
She can talk to her grandchildren whenever she wants and she can travel back to Russia once a year. But having a comfortable life is a big change and idle hands are difficult to get used to. In the Soviet Union and Russia, all the Koreans fought to survive. Many people from this generation like my grandmother never learned how to just enjoy life. And with all of this time and no grandchildren around to take care of it wasn't an easy feeling. Yule Dinsgrandfather repatriated to South Korea in the early 2000s. And she says she thinks about something her grandfather said to her.
她可以随时与她的孙子孙女交谈，她每年可以回俄罗斯一次。但过上舒适的生活是一个巨大的改变，无所事事是很难习惯的。在苏联和俄罗斯，所有的朝鲜人都在为生存而战。这一代中的许多人，比如我的奶奶，从未学会如何仅仅去享受生活。而且有这么多的时间和没有孙子孙女在身边照顾，并不是一种容易适应的感觉。尤利娅·季娜的祖父在20世纪2000年代初被遣返到韩国。她说她想起了她祖父对她说过的一句话。
When she asked him how he liked Korea, he told her that there was nothing to do there, except one thing. To stare out of the window and wait until you die. to stare out of the window and wait until you die. But the biggest criticism with the Repatriation Program was that it was only available to a select few who qualified. Those who were born before August 15, 1945. The program was on-lope into what they called the first generation of Sakhling Koreans. This was the people who had been born prior to the end of World War II. This generation would be allowed to return to Korea and would be financially supported,
当她问他是否喜欢韩国时，他告诉她那里没有什么可做的，除了有一件事。那就是盯着窗外，直到你死去。盯着窗外，直到你死去。但对遣返项目最大的批评是，它只对少数符合条件的人开放。那些在1945年8月15日之前出生的人。该项目仅限于他们所称的第一代萨哈林朝鲜人。这些人是在二战结束前出生的人。这一代人将被允许返回韩国并获得经济支持，
but only if they were willing to live behind the families that they had built on Sakhling. So in attempting to reunify separated families in Korea, the repatriation program ended up causing even more family separations. I mean, ideally, you just allow your whole family to come. However, imagine that you have already three generations. The first generation, second generation, third generation. So Tatyana, you are third generation? Yep.
但前提是他们愿意留下他们在萨哈林建立的家庭。因此，在试图让韩国的离散家庭团聚的过程中，遣返项目最终导致了更多的家庭分离。我的意思是，理想情况下，你只是允许你的整个家庭都来。然而，想象一下你已经有了三代人。第一代、第二代、第三代。所以塔蒂亚娜，你是第三代？是的。
Depending on the age when they were born, even second generation already they lost quite a bit of Korean language and as a South Korea it would be a foreign country. So this is the tragedy of the diaspora, right? Here's Jihun Park again. When they leave Sakhalin and go back to Korea, Now their homeland has become Sahallin. And then that takes some years for them to process. Oh God, it was not the land. Actually, it was the people that I was attached to. And then my people now in Sahallin, my homeland is now, my home is in Sahallin now.
根据他们出生时的年龄，甚至第二代人也已经失去了相当多的朝鲜语，而且对他们来说韩国会是一个外国。所以这就是海外侨民的悲剧，对吧？这里又是朴智衡。当他们离开萨哈林回到韩国时，现在他们的家乡变成了萨哈林。这需要他们花一些年去处理。天哪，那不是土地。实际上，是我依恋的人。而我的人现在在萨哈林，我的家乡现在是，我的家现在在萨哈林了。
My home is in Sahani now. In 2020, new legislation was passed that expanded the eligibility requirements for Soklin Koreans to repatriate. Now, the first generation are allowed to bring one direct descendant and that person's spouse. But for a lot of younger Soklin Koreans, it's less about returning to an ancestral homeland than it is a practicality. For them, there are both opportunities and obligations waiting in South Korea. My mom actually moved to Kohangma'il to care for my grandmother just last year. She is grateful for the chance to come to South Korea. They don't need to worry about rent on the apartment and she gets good health care there.
我的家现在在萨哈林了。在2020年，通过了一项新的立法，扩大了萨哈林朝鲜人遣返的资格要求。现在，第一代被允许带上一名直系亲属和该亲属的配偶。但对于许多年轻的萨哈林朝鲜人来说，这与其说是返回祖先的家乡，不如说是一种权宜之计。对他们来说，韩国有等待着他们的机遇和义务。我的妈妈去年刚刚搬到故乡村照顾我的奶奶。她很感激有机会来到韩国。他们不需要担心公寓的租金，而且她在那里能得到很好的医疗保健。
But for Sakhling Koreans, my mom's age, moving there is a completely different experience. I think, to the bones of my mother, I'm still Russian. I haven't used it yet, so when I think of Russia, I'm like a fish. My mom says that deep in her bones she is a Russian. In Russia, she feels like a fish in the pond. But in Korea, it's so little difficult. Even though she speaks the language, she still has trouble communicating with native Koreans, especially the younger ones.
但对于我妈妈这个年纪的萨哈林朝鲜人来说，搬到那里是一种完全不同的体验。我想，深入我母亲的骨髓里，我仍然是个俄罗斯人。我还没习惯，所以当我想到俄罗斯时，我就像一条鱼。我妈妈说，深入她的骨髓，她是一个俄罗斯人。在俄罗斯，她觉得如鱼得水。但在韩国，这太困难了。尽管她会说这门语言，但在与当地韩国人尤其是年轻人交流时，她仍然有困难。
Despite all the assistance that the South Korean and Japanese governments have provided, or the legislation that has been passed or housing complexes that were built, it simply isn't enough. Repatriation came 50 years too late. Much of the first generation who yearned to return to South Korea died long before the program started, and the people who did live to see their homeland again were too old to make the most of it. J. Hyeong Park says that the word where Go-hyeong Ma-il gets its name from is a powerful word in Korean. The literal translation is hometown, but it's a much bigger, Korea and it's like a very much, how you say? It's an emotional one, right?
尽管韩国和日本政府提供了所有的援助，或者通过了立法，或者建造了住宅小区，但这根本不够。遣返来得太晚了50年。渴望返回韩国的第一代人中的很大一部分在项目开始前很久就去世了，而那些活着再次见到祖国的人已经太老了，无法充分享受它。朴智衡说，“故乡村”这个名字的由来在韩语中是一个强有力的词。字面翻译是家乡，但它是一个大得多的概念，朝鲜语里，它是一个非常……怎么说呢？这是一个情感上的词，对吧？
Yeah, it's an emotional one. It's not attached necessarily to the concept of the nation. It's a land concept that is like a particular town village that they are born. People want to go back to the same particles, you know, in the land, same earth, same plants, trees around them. And that's where they believed that they were rooted. There is a monument in Savelin at the port in Korsaka.
对，这是一个情感上的词。它不一定与国家的概念相连。它是一个土地概念，就像他们出生的特定小镇村庄。人们想要回到土地上的同一个地方，你知道的，同一片土地，同一片泥土，周围相同的植物、树木。这就是他们相信自己扎根的地方。在萨哈林的科尔萨科夫港有一个纪念碑。
It's a tall metal statue that looks like an abstract pair of sails pointing towards the sea. This monument is dedicated to the tens of thousands of forgotten Koreans who never got a chance to go home. I visited back in February. Starting in since I'm a sub-the-first recording. I'm at the Corsica port. Corsica is a small town. I see small houses. There is a plaque, of course. I translated some of it from Russian.
这是一个高大的金属雕像，看起来像一对抽象的指向大海的风帆。这座纪念碑献给成千上万从未有机会回家的被遗忘的朝鲜人。我在二月份回去拜访了。从我录音开始。我在科尔萨科夫港。科尔萨科夫是一个小镇。我看到小房子。当然，那里有一块牌匾。我把其中的一部分从俄语翻译了过来。
To those who haven't got to meet their motherland. August 1945. In Corsica port, there were 2,000 of our peers. I actually moved from Russia to the US a few months ago and wanted to visit the monument before I left. Anyway, it made me feel closer to this story. Even though I was leaving the country by choice, it wasn't clear when I'd be able to return home to Sao Hling. My dad actually drove me to the monument and on the way back we started talking about the 1988 Solar Olympics
致那些未能见到祖国的人。1945年8月。在科尔萨科夫港，有2000名我们的同胞。我几个月前实际上从俄罗斯搬到了美国，在离开之前想去参观一下纪念碑。无论如何，这让我觉得离这个故事更近了。尽管我是自愿离开这个国家的，但还不清楚我什么时候能够回到萨哈林。我爸爸实际上开车送我去了纪念碑，在回来的路上，我们开始谈论1988年的首尔奥运会，
and what it must have been like to see his homeland on television. He made a very important distinction that I hadn't really thought about before. Of the Tibet chasrojina. I hadn't seen you a know that Korea was his homeland, but my dad corrected me. No, for me it's not like that. Korea is just like a cheese. He said that the Soviet Union is his homeland.
以及在电视上看到他的祖国会是什么样子。他做了一个非常重要的区分，这是我以前没有真正想过的。关于故乡。我以前不知道朝鲜是他的祖国，但我爸爸纠正了我。不，对我来说不是这样的。朝鲜就像是芝士。他说苏联是他的祖国。
Korea is his motherland. Motherland is the place that you are connected to by your ancestors. And even though he feels Korean, it will never feel like home. This is from a home video of my babushka. My grandmother from my father's side. It was her birthday back in the year 2000. She's standing and singing at her dining room table, which is full of Russian and Korean food.
朝鲜是他的母国。母国是你通过祖先与之相连的地方。尽管他觉得自己是朝鲜人，但它永远不会感觉像家。这段视频来自我的巴布什卡的家庭录像。我父亲那边的祖母。那是她2000年的生日。她站在餐桌旁唱歌，桌上摆满了俄式和韩式食物。
Friends and relatives of both Korean and Russian descent are sitting together, drinking vodka, maybe a little too much vodka. She passed away in 2020, and I wish that I could have talked to her for this story. I will always remember how easily she moved between three languages, Korean, Russian, and Japanese. She mixed them up and made her own unique words and phrases. Babushka decided to remain on Saal and even though she was given the chance to leave. I'm so grateful that she stayed because she was a huge influence on my life. So much of me came from her.
拥有朝鲜和俄罗斯血统的朋友和亲戚坐在一起，喝着伏特加，也许喝了有点太多伏特加。她于2020年去世，我希望我能为这个故事采访她。我将永远记住她在三种语言（朝语、俄语和日语）之间切换是多么自如。她把它们混合在一起，创造出自己独特的词汇和短语。巴布什卡决定留在萨哈林，尽管她得到了离开的机会。我非常感谢她留下来，因为她对我的生活产生了巨大的影响。我的很多部分都来自于她。
The history of Koreans in Saeho-lin is a sad one, but it's not only about loss. I want to believe that it's also about the creation of something entirely new, a new mixed culture, new perspectives, new families, new lives. Even though Korea, Japan and Russia all had difficult political relationships with one another, Babushka brought the best parts of each identity together. She embraced them all to make something wonderful and different exactly where she was. She is a boy! She is a boy! She is a boy! She is a boy! The story was produced by Tautana Kim and Vivian Le, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald. Coming up, we wrap up the future of...
萨哈林朝鲜人的历史是悲伤的，但它不只是关于失去。我愿意相信它也是关于创造全新事物的过程——一种新的混合文化、新的视角、新的家庭、新的生活。尽管韩国、日本和俄罗斯彼此之间有着困难的政治关系，但巴布什卡将每个身份中最美好的部分融合在了一起。她拥抱了所有这些，在她的所在地创造了奇妙而不同的东西。她是博伊！她是博伊！她是博伊！她是博伊！这个故事由塔蒂亚娜·金和薇薇安·李制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑。接下来，我们将总结……
Over the last several months, we produced a series of episodes called The Future of Da Da Da. With the support of the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation, we produced a series of episodes called The Future of Data-Data. With the support of the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation, we've been exploring how changes the way we live, learn, work, and play may shape our health and well-being in years to come. The project was conceived at the very start of the COVID pandemic, so even though the features that we were looking at went well beyond that immediate health crisis, we used that drastic shake-up in our lives and routines to really look at our accepted status quo with fresh eyes. Our first episode was all about
在过去的几个月里，我们制作了一系列名为“……的未来”的节目。在罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会的支持下，我们制作了一系列名为“……的未来”的节目，一直在探索我们生活、学习、工作和娱乐方式的变化将如何在未来几年塑造我们的健康和福祉。这个项目构思于新冠疫情爆发之初，因此，尽管我们审视的特征远远超出了眼前的健康危机，但我们利用生活和日常中的这一剧烈震荡，以崭新的视角审视我们接受的现状。我们的第一集全部关于
the future of the office. It turned out that people have been going back and forth about what makes a healthy and productive office since there have been offices. So, you know, Facebook, when they were first emerging as a company they bought the old Sun Microsystems building in Menlo Park and doubled the amount of people in the same office space. Of course they didn't pitch it that way. They said oh my god this is so amazing. We have all this collaborative collisions and spontaneous interactions because everyone's in here and then they hired Frank Gary to design this giant warehouse next to the doubled-in-size sun-micro systems. And to me, that building looks exactly like the rose of desks of
办公室的未来。事实证明，自打有办公室以来，人们一直在争论究竟是什么构成了健康且高效的办公室。所以，你知道的，Facebook，当他们刚作为一家公司崭露头角时，他们买下了门洛帕克的旧太阳微系统公司大楼，并将同一办公空间里的人数翻了一番。当然，他们不是那样宣传的。他们说，哦天哪，这太棒了。我们有所有这些协作式的碰撞和自发的互动，因为每个人都在这里，然后他们雇用了弗兰克·盖里在加倍大小的太阳微系统公司旁边设计了这个巨大的仓库。对我来说，那建筑看起来完全像……的办公桌排。
like little telephone banks that secretaries had in the 1950s. But it was supposed to be so radical and so amazing that everybody was on the same floor and they were all going to be so innovative, but it's like so retrograde. The next episode was all about the future of broadband, which has become an essential utility in the modern world, but a last mile problem and a consortium of private internet service providers are keeping it from reaching all the people who need it. The goal of for-profit companies will always be to make money, which is why a lot of people still believe that quality internet access for everyone
就像20世纪50年代秘书们用的小电话银行一样。但它本应是如此激进而惊人，每个人都在同一层楼，而且他们都将如此具有创新性，但它却如此复古。下一集全部关于宽带的未来，宽带已成为现代世界必不可少的公用事业，但“最后一英里”问题和私人互联网服务提供商财团正在阻止它惠及所有需要它的人。营利性公司的目标将永远是赚钱，这就是为什么许多人仍然相信，每个人都能获得优质的互联网服务
means eventually treating broadband as a right, not just a commodity. And that requires intervention by people who are accountable to votes and not just dollars. Then we looked at the future of public health data and how an interconnected global population requires more modern approaches to the gathering and sharing of information critical to our survival. There are just so many examples of how our COVID data was unstandardized or incomplete.
意味着最终将宽带视为一项权利，而不仅仅是一件商品。这需要对选票负责而不仅仅对美元负责的人进行干预。然后我们探讨了公共卫生数据的未来，以及相互联系的全球人口如何需要更现代的方法来收集和共享对我们生存至关重要的信息。有太多的例子表明我们的新冠数据是如何标准化程度不高或不完整的。
Like, did you know that a lot of our local health departments are still at the mercy of fax machines? And finally, we still at the mercy of facts machines. And finally, we looked at the future of environmental law and conservation, with the rise of the environmental personhood movement. Rights of nature is pretty much what it sounds like, the idea that you could treat nature like a person, legally. Each story will entertain you and get your thinking about the future that we're all about to share.
比如，你知道我们的许多地方卫生部门仍然受传真机的摆布吗？最后，我们展望了环境法和保护的未来，随着环境人格运动的兴起。大自然权利基本上就是字面意思，即在法律上你可以像对待一个人一样对待大自然。每个故事都会让你感到娱乐，并让你思考我们即将共同面对的未来。
All episodes are out now to scroll through or search the 99% invisible feed for the future of and listen. Thanks to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for their support. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Tatiana Kim and Vivian Lei edited by Emmet Fitzgerald, fact-checking by Graham Haysha, Mix and Tech Production by Martin Gonzales, Music by a director of sound, Swan Rial. Translation by a very own 99PI intern, Sarah Baker. You came just in the nick of time. Special thanks this week.
所有剧集现已上线，您可以滚动浏览或在 99% Invisible 订阅源中搜索“future of”并收听。感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会的大力支持。本周的《99% Invisible》由塔蒂亚娜·金（Tatiana Kim）和维维安·雷（Vivian Lei）制作，埃met·菲茨杰拉德（Emmet Fitzgerald）剪辑，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）核实事实，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzales）负责混音和技术制作，音乐由声音总监斯旺·里尔（Swan Rial）创作。翻译由我们自己的 99PI 实习生萨拉·贝克（Sarah Baker）完成。你来得真是时候。特别感谢本周的...
To E Soon Young, Park Sun Ok, E Soon Dinn, Ha Soon E, Kim Yoon Chow, Kim Okie, and of course, to Tatiana's Babushka,
李顺英、朴顺玉、李顺丁、河顺伊、金润周、金玉伊，当然还有塔蒂亚娜的奶奶，
Moon Ha Ok. 99% visible to executive producer is Delaney Hall. Kurt Kohl set is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Baroupe, Christopher Johnson, Losh Madon, Sophia Klatsker, Jason De Leon, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of the Stitcher & Serious XM podcast family,
文哈玉。《99% Invisible》执行制片人是德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。库尔特·科尔塞特（Kurt Kohlstedt）是数字总监。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁普（Chris Baroupe）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、洛什·马多恩（Losh Madon）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason De Leon）、乔·罗森博格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，
now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora Building. You're beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. On Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Редактор субтитров А.Семкин Корректор А.Егорова Подайте, а-а-а! В ней лыло и коров! И за дождой, а-а-а! И с днём, когда дружит. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
总部现已迁往奥克兰市中心潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你们很美。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，也可以@节目 @99PI org。Instagram 和 Reddit 上也有。您可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜爱的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的所有往期节目。字幕编辑 A.谢姆金，校对 A.叶戈罗娃。给点儿吧，啊——！里面有牛和奶牛！还有雨，啊——！还有友好相处的那一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。